pull up this story we got this from the
poster Millennial Georgia state senator
moves to impeach Trump prosecutor Fannie
Willis Moore said we must strip all
funding and if appropriate impeach Fanny
Willis so he dreaded this letter I
believe uh oh they don't they don't have
it he said we the undersigned being the
duly elected members of the Georgia
House of House of Representatives and
Georgia Senate and comprising
three-fifths of each respective house
pursuant to article 4 section 2
paragraph 7B hereby certify you in
writing with a copy of to the Secretary
of State that in our opinion an
emergency exists in the Affairs of the
state requiring a special session to be
convened under that section for all
purposes including uh for all purposes
to include without limitation the review
in response to the actions of Fanny
Willis so this is a Georgia Senator
Colton Moore who apparently went on to
say that they must defund or impeach if
appropriate now I'm not entirely
convinced they'll do anything I don't
trust Georgia Republicans at all but
I'm curious where this goes I'm not so
sure this ends with Trump simply
surrendering we've already got Mark
Meadows filing to have this move to
Federal Court a bunch of analysts
believe that will happen very very
quickly uh you've got John Eastman
severing his his case from the rest of
the group saying his defense is
different from theirs and then you've
got
the attempts to remove the prosecutor I
think Donald Trump should immediately
his lawyer should be filing a claim this
is interesting to me because why isn't
this happening should be the first thing
we heard his lawyers file with the
federal government on the challenging
the constitutionality of trying to have
him arrested right that should be the
first thing that happens for a state in
a state court for a federal election but
apparently Trump is agreeing to
surrender he's apparently negotiating
there's a bigger point I grew up in
Rhode Island where organized crime Rico
was used largely for organized crime in
the ma in Mafia right the idea that you
are now and you made this point about
Jenna Ellis a while ago there are people
who if you read the indictment and what
they're being charged with the different
counts and indictment it's like tweeted
did this Representatives they are
creating a criminal Enterprise under a
statute that was made to go after
organized crime because mob bosses would
Escape because they're like ah
technically I didn't do that or whatever
but this is I I've been involved in two
really close elections 1994 uh was
involved in a race that lost by 21 votes
on Election night and then 2000 we one
by 386 votes the first thing you do is
you're out there claiming that you won
you're making sure that you exhaust
every recourse in terms of petitioning
the government talking in like they
nothing that they did in this case
is less than expressing yourself under
the laws that exist in our constitution
to to participate in a democracy they
are creating a criminal Enterprise by
saying this is this goes back to what
we're talking about this is how far
they're going yeah
it feels like a sort of slip on George's
part right they see them as criminals so
they're going to make them into
criminals you even saw Chris Christie
who is literally all he talks about his
entire campaign is Trump no Trump no
more Trump his entire he came out and
said this is a mistake how they're
handling this because I think again
they've they've jumped the shark they
keep going one step further and in her
case it was because I want to show
everyone in the world that I can be the
champion that slays the Dragon
yeah and they've got unhinged supporters
on social you you know I think one big
component of the culture War has been
that Fringe weirdos on social media
drive the conversation among Democrats
and when they started Banning
conservatives something interesting
happened
you've got I want you to imagine there's
two kids one's filthy and covered in
chocolate ice cream all over his face he
knows like a disaster and the other kids
very clean looking and you know his hair
is parted perfectly and he's wearing a
nice little suit and you think man that
kid's you know well well educated well
well taken care of and well developed
and Advocate is something's wrong with
them you assume the dirty kid is got
something wrong with them the reality is
the mother just does not let the other
kid have chocolate ice cream and if he
can't get access to it he can't get all
messy the other kid she lets him have it
so what we're seeing with the censorship
on so on Twitter they kept allowing the
left to say the craziest things
imaginable but the right would be banned
instantly what happened is you got a
perception of the right as Ben Shapiro
saying well listen you know these are
the arguments we're going to have
they're completely on the taxes and it's
very basic very normal conservatism on
the left you have people arguing that
you can be a chimp if you want you just
need to get the appropriate surgery and
so now you end up with post-liberals and
and uh disaffected liberals people who
are like I can't associate with this
Democratic politicians on social media
are adhering to the voices of the most
Fringe and insane personalities and
people on the right were listening to a
bunch of regular moderately conservative
individuals this made Democrat
politicians sound like crackpots when
they start advocating for child sex
changes and sex chose for sex shows for
children now you get regular people
being like yo that that's crazy that's
too far for me because they were allowed
to say these things and social media
wouldn't ban it yeah well think about it
you brought up sound of Freedom before I
I uh I started before I actually saw the
movie I started going what's all this Q
Anon stuff right I finally watched the
entire I'm like I'd seen the clips I'd
watch the trailer I talked to a bunch of
the guys and then I kept saying like I
just don't get the Q Anon thing no I I
mean literally if you watch but this is
what they do they demonized it and what
happened is more people said I gotta
watch it it became unbelievably
successful but they they they don't know
where to stop Q Anon it has there's
nothing like but that used to be the
thing they would say to keep people away
they're saying that about Oliver Anthony
they're saying he's a q Anon guy wait
they're still using it I'm just saying
it's not as effective as it used to be
before when you would say Q Anon people
would be like Ah that's that's crazy
internet stuff and now you say cunan
people are like oh that means mainstream
people in the media don't like it and
therefore maybe I should check it out on
my own there is a Reawakening of
curiosity and it didn't work like people
went and saw that movie in drove yeah
and they're still going 175 million
basically yeah beating Indiana Jones and
a bunch of other films for like the top
box office for the year absolutely
incredible and the budget was really
small so it's actually performing web
better than we can even realize some of
these movies it's like oh it made 500
million dollars and it cost 600. yeah we
don't come on sound of Freedom was 15
million and said 175 million and again
Bud Light and all these other things
I I think we win culturally and then
what happens is Oliver Anthony is a
really great example John Rich tweeted
this out that all these labels are
tripping of themselves trying to get him
on board or sign with him but if he he
said if if Anthony was signed to these
labels they wouldn't let that song Right
you'd never hear it yeah no why don't
you write a song about drinking beer
with your dog in your truck because your
girl left you or something not about
miners on an island or whatever now
that's that's a bit too much so it's
Grassroots effort but the culture
matters because money talks and Bs walks
Disney and all these organizations
they're losing money
they're going to have to fall in line or
their money is going to dry up
yeah that was similar is that the money
like Alex Jones got slammed I don't know
if slander's the right word but he got
you know demeaned in the media got
talked badly about then he got deleted
from Twitter uh but then when they went
after his pocketbook that's when it
really stifled his ability to create now
he's working for Stephen Crowder I think
he's working with he has a special with
mug Club but Alex Jones and Infowars are
all still doing their thing but they
just shredded his organization
financially and caused him so much
stress for years and they see they're
doing Donald Trump through the legal
system like you can talk crap about
someone only so long before it turns
against you but if you go after Finance
I think that is a way to permanently
destroy someone's ability to communicate
yeah doesn't Alex Jones oh like the GDP
of France or something billions of
dollars it makes it I mean I would think
if you were the the people suing him you
know you're never gonna see that money
so if you really felt like you needed it
to fund whatever
whoever is acting on your behalf is
actually trying to make a political
point and presumably they are also in on
it I think that's the whole point of our
justice system right now especially
because so much of it plays out uh in
the court of public opinion it's not
about actual Justice or figuring out
what's right or wrong it's about getting
the much mug shots about getting the
perp walk it's about getting headlines
being able to say well I was the one who
filed charges I was the one who did this
I served on that jury and we did this
thing and therefore I have the moral
superiority and that's it people feel
like they have influence they just want
a Wikipedia page man I'm thinking lights
all they want like how Alex sacrificed
uh his financial you know stability or
had it it was sacrificed on the altar in
front of him and he watched and watched
it happen it's like the founding fathers
of the United States they they risked
everything man they risked their
fortunes as well like at some point you
speak out against it they might shut
your bank account off but like you got
to take that risk if you if you want to
speak what you believe there's a risk
involved and there's probably the risk
will probably intensify in the come
coming
five years probably by 2027 we're going
to see a sea change that's when graphene
goes Peak I think that's when money
might not be that become way way less
important I think the value of money
actually is going to be can continue to
diminish we'll see what happens with
that I mean uh Michael burry we talked
about the other day made a big bet
against the S P 500 and NASDAQ and so
everyone's kind of like looking around
like does he know something exactly he
doesn't mean he does he got he got the
mortgage-backed Securities things right
in 2008 doesn't mean he's a prophet
means he got one big one right
I don't know I don't know if I want to
hope he's right this time or not I mean
a shock to the system could be good it
could be bad I have no idea I think
ultimately the scary thing is it's going
to negatively impact working-class
people who are already having a hard
enough time buying groceries
yeah I just like to know when that's
gonna happen
second plan well a SpaceX what SpaceX
sold all their Bitcoin today or
something like that are they really and
then the price of Bitcoin collapsed and
then they announced ETF ethereum ETF or
whatever Futures and then it jumped back
up so it's like yeah everyone would have
loved to have known that SpaceX was
about to sell off their Bitcoin so they
could get out before price went down but
yeah everything dropped six percent
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time